boa noite boa noite na escada bom dia
nesta cidade enfrentar alguns já está
pensado eu quero começar por dizer que
ao longo das últimas florestas a
instituição a chuva atinge foi sendo
convidado pra vida que falar e partilhar
um crime das minhas histórias de viagens
que aliás é uma coisa que eu não vou
fazer mas fui sido convidado
tive sempre a justificação de de estava
na índia estava mesmo eu estando tive a
sorte ou o azar destacar aqui para dizer
algumas coisas convosco
quando percebi que o alvo era quem era
alguns que está aqui achei que tinha seu
rock'n'roll e quando vi que ia ser o
último a se apresentar dois pensamentos
rapidamente no passado pela crença
nós vamos atacar ninguém por isso não há
grande expectativa vai correr bem
ou então por outro lado é que vou ter na
qual vai apresentar tal dos pés com
alguns tons e não saibam seus olhos onde
espero que o meu pai como um homem
positivo ver as coisas pelo seu ponto de
vista e vamos sim alguns a este processo
e tudo que vai falar hoje com vocês é
convosco é é algo que é muito traumático
eu acho crise
o processo dela pra dentro do script de
nós próprios
é algo que pra mim pelo menos
pessoalmente implica muito sofrimento
leste constantemente gosta diários
processo porque algum custa é com as
minhas viagens ao ano ao longo dos
outros 20 anos viajar especialmente pela
índia
o esse processo do nosso especialmente
dramático confrontar com realidades
muito diferentes da minha realidade com
traz muito diferente da minha e todas
aquelas convicções que falava com certas
e adquiridas seria igual em todo mundo
com respeito pelo ser humano empatia
tudo isso a olhar e ver a tentar
perceber outras culturas
percebi que ela estava completamente
errado e mesmo hoje quando falam disto e
quando para esta apresentação sempre
para a última hora é mesmo hoje é algo
que não tem plena convicção por isso que
eu vou dizer aqui é minha convicção
plena em dois minutos o craque nas
minutos não é o que você vai dizer é
algo que é mesmo muito muito muito
dramático é algo que não impacta muito
deixando muitas vezes triste é de 49
fazendo um dos outros 20 anos se calhar
este pensamento que o senhor hoje
senhoras pontos pela primeira vez surgiu
na cabeça
mais ou menos seis anos atrás uma viagem
à índia
é algo que vai durar muito triste em
dizer o amor não existe
logo na vida é que lá eu vou explicar
porque nós ouvimos muitas palestras no
vídeo no youtube agora é tarde diz
motivos sinais que andam do nosso nas
ruas a para dentro com pessoas que falam
com microfones com esta é a primeira vez
que tenho um profundo desta ilha que as
pessoas falam muito mas não né
dizem que temos que acreditar na morte
de acreditar nos sonhos e que é seu
sogro nos move é exatamente o amor
o morto outro ser humano o que eu quero
dizer é que isso é conversa da treta não
é votar a mensagem que eu ficar hoje é
como se fosse uma pedra vai até lá em
cima da nossa cabeça
a realidade é verdadeiramente dramático
que eu quero dizer é que o amor é uma
acção cultural
eu estou a falar do amor de um pai por
uma filha minha filha eu fiz aqui é o
vôo estava muito muito bom
girando é falar do amor de um pai e uma
filha de um mãe por um filho este amor
familiar visto as de vínculo genético
que existe e as amor tem que ser essa
carga genética que está a ser negociada
mas mesmo essa morto dentro de um pai
por uma filha é um amor que é adquirido
que é construído
eu não existe é claro que este amor que
tenho pela minha filha eu tenho
expectativas prenda minha filha só isso
com minha filha dela da minha troca no
braço e beijinhos uma criança de quatro
anos da sua relação bilateral direcional
eu tenho expectativa sobre ela e ela tem
outras coisas expectativas também espero
cumprir nos próximos anos
não é de agora
olha vou falar do amor de um homem por
uma mulher
entre os homens e entre as mulheres é
este amor que você quer falar e este
amor que não existe ao longo da história
também fala da morte só cenário clean
para trás e voltar no fim até o tempo do
renascimento tempo nelas a 20 pela
primeira vez começa a falar do amor
mesmo carinho antes do tempo treinando
meia havia a idéia de que o homem curte
a mulher já no tempo do conhecimento
o humor começa a ser propalado pelo
mundo itaipu vossas ver diferentes
partes do mundo interno então europa nos
mais variadas artes
mas mesmo a maior queda no crescimento
principalmente falava no nascimento
é um amor desigual é o amorim com a
minha nova mulher e mulher colocava na
posição de ser amada
por isso este amor só começa a ser
falado no conhecimento
aliás um pensamento num negócio ou não
escreveu o sem condições disse acusações
se o casamento se basear se no amor e na
amizade e no dia 23 no via mais
adultérios negócios nos dias 2 todos nós
casamos com as pessoas que nós queremos
nós acompanhamos ninguém nos obriga a
nós que andamos todos por amor
juramos amor para interna ou um vídeo
até que passou hoje a meio da tarde
falavam que eles por isso teremos todas
as condições para que realmente não haja
mais um tênis em divórcios
ora em 2007 o cd quatro vozes para 100
casamentos sobre as nossas cabeças a
pensar um treino a pensar que o mundo
não é tão igual ao nosso umbigo à nossa
realidade
qual é o ambiente nós vivemos aqui
dentro
são questões relativamente partidos
relativamente semelhantes
temos todos numerados e judaica que isto
é mais ou menos da mesma cultura uma
moto se lógico
todos nós temos mais ou menos as mesmas
convicções mesmo princípio das coisas
não mudou muito a nossa cabeça e ao
longo de 20 anos na índia vai perceber
que realmente as coisas são vistas
maneiras muito diferentes
eu sou eu ea minha circunstância
uma das coisas que eu aprender é que
nada
enfim mais do que o sítio do nash
eu não suporto sou urbana e isso define
compromente sociologicamente todas as
minhas crenças stuffing completamente
por muito que eu posso viver
experiências diferentes é aquela
identidade cultural que ajudou a
conquistar no nosso caso é algo que está
completamento preso nós na nossa
sociedade nos dias de hoje
nós continuamos a dar um carrinho as
meninas continuem de voltar aos campos
privados com os pilares da nossa cidade
e vão se apresentar para ser
apresentadas entre pares para casarem
entre taxa
as meninas sentadas os meninos para
casarem entre paz dentro mesmo estrato
social
as coisas continuam a funcionar assim
aliás nós olharmos para a história da
europa nos últimos séculos da história
da europa
os príncipes casaram com as princesas e
cada uma com as princesas de famílias 9
porém 3513 tipo matrix tudo isso aquelas
idéias nós ajustamos os casamentos
arranjados uma coisa
salvem do outro lado do mundo é que na
europa e na hoje em dia as coisas
continuam a ser assim
aliás dos casamentos e os
relacionamentos dos princípios do país
com um complexo com o povo não seriam
filhos mais tarde o seu filho seu filho
na cidade pois os preços continuam a
pesar com as princesas entre partos nas
cinco nós casamos em paz
aliás permite mal sabia de poder afirmar
não com toda a certeza absoluta que
provavelmente você não conheceram muita
gente à nossa volta que tenha casado
entre o estado social
nós casamos urbano do porto
khazaee como rapariga urbana e
profissionalmente ficam 70 no estado
social pois aquela vai o amor é da
maneira que se apaixona pela ministra
não são estados muito com os problemas
da nossa vida
nós falamos do amor falamos uma relação
de três em três entre duas pessoas
obviamente que a palavra empresa tem uma
carga dura usada usei uma relação de
interesses entre o assunto
ele acha que nós contamos as pessoas
quando pedimos às pessoas um sinônimo
que possam definir a palavra amor
no momento encontra uma palavra pra ser
amor amor né definido com outras
palavras completamente diferentes como
cúmplice da afinidade em 35 fala a
palavra morte uma palavra não tem
sinônimo da palavra que nós não
conseguimos definir e aliás com os
treinos chama coisa que foi apareceu ao
longo dos últimos séculos e que nas
últimas décadas foi propalada muito mais
garantias
acho realmente se olharem para a
história dos vossos avós ou bisavós a
palavra amor não seria uma palavra muito
comum no conhecimento sobre a nossa
crença não viajaram com ele pra índia e
vamos ver como é que é a realidade
funciona nem e aí como é que é realmente
aquelas coisas que nós temos como
convictas certas dias lutas são
condições intrínsecas ao ser humano você
nem de também a seres humanos somos
todos seres humanos né
todos nós achamos que é intrínseco e
empoderamento querido está ali é uma
condição em 31 que o ser humano está nos
outros lados do planeta olhando com o
espectro com respeito são completamente
diferentes
antes tínhamos a índia este senhor é um
canadiano escreveu as cartas dos 34
direitos do homem muito pós-guerra será
a segunda guerra mundial foi no cias
ensaio dignificar a condição humana e
mais uma vez tomar craniano um homem
como a visão ambiental e história que
vou falar a seguir um caminho de linha
branca carta dos ventos mas não
provavelmente essa história na índia
vips com uma filosofia uma religião um
lado quase mística e espiritual
nós vivemos um carinho na minha opinião
nas senhoras ocidentais de uma família
coisas como nós chamamos vem pra cá uns
chamam o carna onde vana nem ele é virus
um sistema de castas milionário foi
abolido há cem anos continuem treinando
na posição
na índia o povo miserável está o
dinheiro na rua está cheia de fome
considera dentro da sua crença religiosa
espiritual está a cumprir o seu carnaval
o seu carma na sociedade significa isto
que acreditando na reencarnação e é um
pobre miserável que perde na rua na vida
anterior fez qualquer coisa que agora
tem que pagar
significa isso ainda mais não foram
ainda mais profunda que este pobre
miserável vivo com apatia com resignação
e quando preocupação marajá que nem elas
tentam muita riqueza sempre os homens
ricos sustentou sempre muita riqueza num
contraste absoluto com os homens povos
quando passou um marajá este pobre
miserável e dispare é uma palavra que
hoje me fãs usando em português da
escolinha faria não invejo rico e eu
acho que o rico merece ser rico fez
qualquer coisa vou ouvir anterior e é
consequência do seu carma significa por
outro lado que o tamanho rico estará já
em testar hierarquia de castas já tantas
vezes ouvimos falar não tem compaixão
pelo palco não tem empate em são paulo
pois não das mãos das mãos e o pólo
também não acha começa o jogo
por isso quando exposta não é pela rua a
dormir na rua no meio do lixo no meio
dos gatos e este é realidade dos eua
venderam os dois só podem ambicionar ser
melhor seus como marajá se exportar em
muito vai nesta vida e só na próxima
vida
esta é condição que se vive na ilha
esta minha fila indiana ela que volta
com nível liliana e voltando ao amor
quero dizer que o senhor jesus final
nesta segunda chama se lixa e os seus
dois filhos cannon e monroe quando eu
perguntar nicho se ela é 99 ela responda
forma mais simples portanto imaginar ela
disse
nosso país já nos casamentos
nós vamos te cumprimentam padre na ilha
do mel a nossa carta astral e nós temos
95% compatibilidade ou não a 99 e ter
95% compatibilidade é uma coisa rara na
índia e nesse dia eu disse-lhe anário
vários escritórios várias pessoas
passaram pela ilha
o escritor italiano se concentrar
naquilo ava escreveu um livro fantástico
chamado isso o vinho será melhor
apaixonaram e se casaram quando estás
mosteiro foi o amor
o casarão que construiu uma hora
já o gregory dave roberts
o australiano viveu muitas dessas várias
décadas linha escrever um livro
fantástico chamado santarém com toda a
certeza não foi na índia como eu
inventava mas foi lá que foi
aperfeiçoado
mostrando bastante né você já viu um
falso policial anamara sustentar aqui
chama-se francisca e ozelita francisca
pt com o senhor tem agora uma pena você
tá francisco junto de fazer isso
já a itália olha a ale não está
associada que eu ia falar com ricardo
quem está sentado ao lado das suas
mulheres e os seus méritos está sentado
ao lado de seus namorados os seus
namorados está numa posição muito
privilegiada neste momento
olha o lado e pensa na palavra é uma
expressão que é tabelado para sempre com
essas palavras o qual destas opções com
deus é mais aquilo que posso ir além do
outro pra mim
passados 20 anos vai viajar para a índia
é pensar no amor e pensar como é que as
pessoas funcionam a palavra quer tomar
meu lado para sempre é muito mais é essa
expressão é muito mais poderosa do que a
palavra é uma palavra que o novo diz que
não tem significado que nós não
conseguimos ver que uma palavra vazia
esta expressão obre garros até a
eternidade
esta exposição traz com ela precisava
afinidade entre assim como temos agora a
parte final vou passar aqui a conversa
planet pop 9
mas vamos falar um bocadinho melhor de
si
aí o pai saiba 35 acham que é um grande
prazer em áreas rurais
eles foram deixar deus ter um final à
final
richa não tinha assim em ok
a ufam em nova york eu estou com vocês
um tango
william ficou chique à dengue na indy e
fazer bem pra mim é hoje o nome ou a
idade limite de faltas sobre se a ue
quer que a casa vive magna na internet e
entre data do youtube a boys o lyon
leves e anote aí a time b do avaí a
sobra ninguém olhe que já é maior do que
a média é de sair do químico entre o
mtur ea garrafa de água eta ii parece
muito mais um problema ele a band
esperando eles saibam o que é piloto
viaja
eu disse isso à nossa grave garante
meriti
o nicho olhou para nós todos os 1.186
vinotti e depois somos um time jovem com
a escola o menino e fimec nova escola
tim donaghy que o título caracteres
botão faz jogos com esgoto best of do
teste só vingou de dammam causa da volta
do zagueiro que havia garantido o título
de 15 de abril a mãe marisa mas olha é
de luiz mendes havia nele bico ss rápido
a lei sob a nova lei para perante
importa em dólar e saía do mma na série
b o time ainda na festa e marize foi
chefe econômico mostrou a festa
levo meu amor que chapa disse marina em
nova iorque mattinson se eu também você
entende time todo seguinte beto foi os
anos em cena e roni que assim noite
espera e mais bônus sabbiadoro soltaram
e foram mais de 80 era viés o sonho de
sair do morro apenas foram chamados mas
carla bastando de rádio em portugal
tempo e r 6 milhões de hectares
rio há quem ache feia para a admissão da
lista a barba
ae
para terminar esse espaço aqui chama se
mano estuda no final da campanha vocês
estrangeiro formato que não precisa dele
para micro soft que vai ter um casamento
arranjado
sim não existe unidos partilham a
francisca não vai entrar daqui a dois
dias fazem quatro anos e três meses
[Aplausos]
o censo foi construído foi mais fácil
mas não é
[Aplausos]
[Música]